as a physician
the
so everything you've seen we've talked
about 80 percent
of the impact on health is lifestyle
how do we live longer what advice would
you give to general people what what
space
of ideas
result in living longer and higher
quality lives right this is a very
simple question to answer exercise
for at least a half hour
at least five times a week
number one
number two don't smoke
number three maintain a reasonably
healthy body weight some people argue
that being
lower than a bmi of 25 is healthy
i think that may be true but i think
getting above 30 is unhealthy and that
ought to be now that's largely uh
largely impacted by socioeconomic status
and we don't want to blame the victims
here so we've got to understand that
when we talk about all of these things
not cigarettes but
exercise
in a good diet and
maintaining a healthy body weight
we have to include in doing those things
the
impediments to people of lower
socioeconomic status being able to make
those changes we've got to understand
that
personal responsibility accounts for
some of this
but also social circumstances accounts
for some of it
and
back to your fishbowl analogy if you're
swimming
in a fishbowl if you live in a fish tank
that's not being properly maintained
the approach wouldn't be to treat
individual
sick fish it would be to fix your
fish tank to get the bacteria out of it
and
whatever bad stuff is in there and make
your fish tank healthier well we invest
far less than the other wealthy
countries do we're flipped we have the
mirror image in the spending on social
determinants of health and medical
determinants of health we have exactly
the wrong order and not only does that
choke off social determinants of health
which are very important but actually
just the ratio
even if you were spending
if we raise the social
spending and raise the our medical
spending in proportion it's the ratio of
social spending to medical spending
that's the problem
so and why do we do that well the answer
is perfectly obvious that the way to
transfer money from working americans to
investors
is through the biomedical model
not through the social health model
and that's the problem for and i
i'd like to discuss this because
the market isn't going to get us
to a reasonable allocation all the other
wealthy countries that are so much
healthier than we are and spending so
much less than we are
have some form of government
intervention in in the quality of the
health data that's available in the
budgeting of health and social um
factors
uh and we don't we're kind of the wild
west and we let the market determine
those allocations and it's it's a
an awful failure it's a horrendous
failure
you